hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
ask a question from one of my newsletter
readers Lynette who wrote in asking Evan
I'm 17 years old and I'm an aspiring
entrepreneur my interests are in the oil
industry and it's becoming a dealer for
oil companies and also in the catering
industry I would like to pursue my dream
immediately after i finished my
secondary education this year so thanks
for the question and congrats being a
young entrepreneur is awesome brings me
back to when I was finishing up high
school and one in set my own business as
well my best advice here is if you were
to determine you're really passionate
about this so if it's the oil industry
you're really excited about it this is
where you want to spend your future I
don't know how much you know yet about
the oil industry maybe you're you know
kid genius and know everything but
chances are you probably I need to get a
little bit of experience in there to be
able to create your company I try to
find a company who you look up to and go
work for them just to get that
experience if it's for a year to learn
the ropes and I try to find a company
that that is not too big so I don't want
you to get locked into a huge
corporation where you're doing one thing
all day you're not learning and you're
you're set under your corporate ladder I
guess what I try to look for is an
opportunity to work with a smaller
company someone with five to ten
employees who's doing what you want to
do where you can learn a lot take on a
lot of responsibilities and I try to get
close to the owner not just do your job
but ask for anything else you could do
to help and basically you're trying to
learn how to be an entrepreneur in that
field it'll do two things one it'll
teach you about the business and see do
you want to do this type of work or not
and two it'll give you an education so
you'll learn exactly what you need to do
to run a business in the oil industry
and the more you can tie into the
entrepreneur own or that you're working
for and take on projects learn about how
they run their company the more of an
education your guy
and you can't I in a lot of those
lessons learned when you start your own
business it doesn't have to take to too
long to do you know if you're if you're
there for six months or a year depending
on how much you're taking on and how
much you're learning you're basically
getting paid to learn about how to be
successful entrepreneur so you can go
and start your own business not have a
lot of experience and try to do things
by guest seine and by trial and error
which is going to take a lot longer and
cost you a lot of money as well and time
to get this thing going oh we go work
for somebody else even it's just for a
short amount of time learning about the
business get paid to do it make some
contacts see what works and what doesn't
work while you're getting paid and then
you have your experience education to go
on and launch your own company so it's
my number on recommendation after making
sure you're passionate about the
business is if you don't have any
experience get some experience by going
to work for another entrepreneur and
again try to find that small company
five to ten employees where you can
really get hands-on and learn about the
business so when you're ready to go
launch your own you have a lot of
experience behind you a lot more than
you get maybe working at a bigger
company where you're on the lower ranks
and you know how to sign a lot of
responsibility so hopefully i helped i'm
not sure if that was the answer you're
looking for but an honest opinion so if
you guys liked the video please give it
a thumbs up below love seeing those come
in and i'd love to hear we get to think
please leave a comment below about this
video or if you have a question for your
own company i'd love to try to answer it
for you if you want leave it below and i
love seeing those come in and it always
makes my day when i turn on the computer
and see those new comments in the videos
so thank you and i'll see you on the
next episode
you